-Welcome back.
I'm hanging out with
Drew Barrymore, everybody.
Oh, my gosh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Every morning. I watch you.
We're about to play a brand-new
game called "Focus Up."
Here we go.
-♪ F-o-o-o-o-ocus Up ♪
-Alright.
Here's how this works.
We're gonna be shown a series
of pixilated images
that are slowly
going to come into focus.
Okay? Now, once you think that
you know what the image is,
you hit this buzzer right here.
If you guess right,
you win a point.
We're gonna play three rounds
with different categories.
-I'm excited.
-You ready to play?
-Yes, 'cause we're both
very competitive.
-Our first category is...
[ Beeping ]
-Album covers?
Oh, did I ruin it?
-Whoa.
-Sorry.
[ Laughter ]
Sorry.
-Did you know
it was album covers?
-No, I think it's, like,
a professional faux pas.
I saw a monitor,
and I was like --
my inner voice was like,
"Read it!"
[ Laughter ]
-That's correct.
You did do --
But this is not planned.
Did you know
that it's album covers?
-It says it in the monitor.
-I know, but...
People watching at home
might think this is rigged.
-[Stiffly] You're right, Jimmy.
I didn't know.
[ Laughter ]
-You -- Hold on a second.
Do you know the answers
to this game?
-I am not purposefully
looking in the monitor now.
I can tell you that.
-No, no, you have to.
No, but -- I mean,
I don't know what this is.
-Are you looking
in the monitor?
Does it have the answer
in there?
-No. It's the category.
-Okay.
It also says, "Okay, Drew,
let's focus up."
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-Alright.
[ Laughter ]
It's not even hooked up
to anything.
Alright. Let's see --
-I hope it is.
-Alright. Here we go.
Let's see the first blur.
Drew, let's focus up.
-Okay.
And start moving it.
Whenever you're ready,
press the buzzer.
It's green. Is it Kermit?
No.
-That would be amazing.
-What is it again?
Album covers. Oh.
-"Let It Be"! "Abbey --"
-"Abbey Road."
Blblblblblblbl!
You're right, you're right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Good job.
See?
That's the thing about Jimmy.
It's all fun and games
until it's game time.
[ Laughter ]
-Then it's not fun?
I'm really competitive.
Alright. Here we go. Alright.
-He will not let you win.
-Alright. Yes, I will!
Let's focus up. Here we go.
It's an album cover.
Go.
-Again? Album cover?
-Is it Flee--
Fleetwood Mac. "Rumors."
[ Bell dings ]
Whoa! [ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Humming "Sanford and Son"
theme song ]
♪♪
Wow! That one. Come on, now.
-That was --
-That was pretty impressive.
-That was insane.
-Yeah. Good.
This game is the best game
in the world!
Alright. Here we go.
Time for round two.
Alright.
Let's get our next category.
Here we go.
[ Beeping ]
Alright, buddy.
-Okay.
-Sitcoms.
Alright. Let's focus up.
-Okay.
-I'm focused.
Alright. Sitcoms?
Okay. Go.
♪♪
Ohh. "ER."
[ Buzzer ]
Oh, I know what it is!
-Wait. Do we get to keep going?
-Yeah, you can keep going.
But then you buzz in.
You get the first buzz.
-I do?
-Go.
-You're just giving it to me.
-You know what it is.
Just say it.
-"Designing Women"?
[ Buzzer ]
-Wait. I was going to say
"Designing Women,"
but now I'm changing it.
It's "Facts of Life."
-[ Bell dinging ]
-Ohh!
-I thought it was
"Golden Girls."
-There was too many
for "Golden Girls."
-Yeah, there were
too many, but, yeah.
-Oh, gosh darn it.
-Tootie. Come on.
Alright. Here we go.
-Tootie, Blair, Jo,
Natalie, and Mrs. Garrett.
-Mrs. Garrett! Come on!
Alright.
Alright. Let's focus up.
♪♪
-This -- This is hard.
-No, it's very hard.
♪♪
Ah! It's got to be
"Golden Girls."
-"Family Ties."
[ Bell dings ]
-It's "Family Ties."
Oh, my gosh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Speaking indistinctly ]
-No, I didn't.
Oh, we have one more!
-Yeah, we have one more.
-One more, one more!
-We have one more.
-I don't think I can win.
-Gosh. "Family Ties."
-I can't win.
-Of course, they're a family.
They're tied together! I get it!
-I know. That's actually
a disturbing image.
-I've never seen that
in my life.
I've never seen that.
-Never.
It's like way too much tied up.
-One of the best shows ever.
-That's like family in crisis.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. "Family Held Hostage."
-Seriously?
That's a real picture?
-I don't know, man. Yeah.
-What were they thinking?
-I like it. I get it.
Now I'm into it.
-No, no. It goes way too far.
It's dark.
-We have a third one
for this category.
Here we go.
Alright. Go.
-Okay. Is it still sitcoms?
-Yeah, sitcoms.
-Okay.
Oh, it's two people.
-"Cagney and Lacey"!
Oh, wait.
[ Buzzer ]
-"Bosom Buddies"?
No. "Perfect Strangers."
[ Buzzer ]
-Alright.
Let it go a little more.
Those were really good guesses.
-Hall and Oates?
♪♪
Ohh! "Laverne and Shirley"!
Come on!
[ Sad tuba plays ]
These are pictures
we've never seen.
They're odd photos
of classic sitcoms.
-Yeah.
-That's a different game.
"Odd Photos of Classic Sitcoms."
[ Laughter ]
You ever see
Kojak skateboarding?
No.
How would I guess "Kojak"?
Alright.
-Oh, final round.
-This is the --
-Wait. Oh, God.
How come none of our numbers
are moving?
I guess we just didn't get any
the last few rounds.
-No. It's 3-1.
You still have time to win.
This last one
is worth 10,000 points.
-Oh, perfect! Okay, great!
-It's the mystery round, Drew.
The mystery round.
-Oh. We need more mystery?
-We don't know the category.
-It's mystery on mystery.
Oh, we don't know the category.
-No, we don't know the category.
It's a mystery.
-Okay.
-Whoever gets this
wins everything.
-Really?
-Yes.
-You're just changing it
to make it fun
because I'm losing.
-No. No, it's not true.
-Alright. Well, let's see --
-Let's see the final image.
Here we go.
-I -- Hm.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
Any -- Before we start playing,
any guesses?
-Oh.
-Looks like the paint aisle
in Home Depot.
-Yeah.
[ Buzzer ]
-Oh, no, I'm kidding. Alright.
Alright, ready? Let's start.
♪♪
Ohh! Come on.
"Fever Pitch."
-Aww.
[ Bell dinging ]
My thanks to Drew Barrymore.
I'm giving it to you, bud.
The best.
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show." Stick around.